yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
light like from Germany Martin Soames
under the National MRSA we have the Slav
the Slav the sloth not sure what is
playing a 6mm ok let's go g3 recently
popular mousse I think a force the way
to to play against that now we very
likely transposed to the five a four
line if he goes e 6 which is there
probably the most common move here yeah
it six it looks a bit strange because it
blocks in the bishop but in this kind of
structure it's hard to develop the
bishop outside of the pawn chain if you
intend them to I mean bishop 105 the
light squares are so weak okay so Bishop
g2 I don't remember really how this is
played I think the capture is s11 move
here and Bishop e3 I believe
hmm I don't really I don't really know
also I believe that chronic allowed the
capture against against Luke McShane but
I just take it let's just take it keep
it simple Jack and 93 is my idea to get
to get the porn back he can take only
three but it's questionable if he will
be able to maintain it in the long run
yeah this is now I think a theoretical
or theoretically known position from the
a four line we just posed to that 5a
form so how to how to continue him
Bishop f4 him yeah probably runs it to
95 so just try to get a look on the C
file
maybe 90 m exchange one pair of nights
93 the night on g 3 sm is nicely placed
that covers lots of important squares be
4 C 5 yeah I wonder about efore f4 is
this is an idea hmm not sure the other
idea that okay let's let's do this first
this look so sensible I am wondering
about capturing and Bishop b4 check and
Bishop c5 that looks that looks strange
but maybe this side then Bishop before
look so quite active check
not probably they can take a bishop c6
it's very very solid for black so did
this Sam didn't really net me much I
mean it wasn't bad or anything but it's
also not much to write home about Luke
team one Rock do you want them and King
III Bishop to c4 or something like that
would improve my position somewhat now
you can try at night b5 to deform it
it's not clear that this is helping it
much that's all very very solid and
logical yeah should I just take or is
there some way to put two to have more
tension in the position I can I cannot
take it and allow night deform I'm not
sure that this is a good idea but ok
let's do that of course you can also
just take c5 just exchange everything ok
so it's a bit more ambitious the smooth
92 of course is a potential
embarrassment so my idea is f wanna of
course undermining the night
well this is necked effectiveness still
at form I can take you from
interesting hmm f4f takes e4 FTC 595
check don't want that okay down in one
minute what this is not good
the position is probably about equal
well I don't want to stay passive him
yeah maybe maybe this is so bad for me
his night no has lost the protecting
yeah yeah the bishop is potentially the
better piece but I'm not sure about this
concrete position because I'm so active
with my king so it is a bit risky
possible a bird this is what I was
thinking about the night is protecting
the aid and my king my king is so
invading rookie six and then
oh don't really have time to calculate
that check what a shame rook is 66 time
warning check
check-check
the position is sound is very dry check
young service is probably the correct
result at the end around around here I'm
very close to with terrific I don't know
maybe I'm overestimating my chance as
possible but this looked I don't know
yeah maybe a term it's it's still all
right with the bishop i mean the the
active king is worth um something but
what i was thinking about is this here
but this is not working due to King
e-cigs I guess he said he's got this
threat the thing is those parts can be
really quick but he's just in time with
the scheme so this is not working and
this means that probably this is it
wrong I thought that my liked my
activity was was worth something maybe I
should have taken taken this after on 96
yeah it will probably end in a draw
anyway okay thanks for watching